les émirs parle maintenant de danse avec
les stars l'émission était le nouveau
titre de sites de rencontre alors là
c'est hallucinant donc l'idylle de la
semaine c'est une miss c'est iris mythe
hainard en couple avec son danseur de
l'émission danse avec les stars
anthony colette on sait que depuis deux
mois elle s'est séparée de notre ami kev
adams et il ya encore beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup d'autres couples vous allez
voir que ce soit en france ou en
angleterre où il ya eu 14 couples qui se
sont formés depuis le début d'histoire
de l'émission regardez
bravo c'était samedi dernier sur le
plateau de danse avec les stars sur tf1
tu iris mittenaere et anthony cole est
plus sexy que jamais depuis la rumeur
court
séparés depuis septembre avec l'acteur
qu'eva dams l'ancienne miss univers
serait aujourd'hui en couple avec son
danseur
et sur instagram l'un comme l'autre sème
le doute
je suis fou deviner à cause de qui
une ambiguïté sur laquelle surfe
également la production de l'émission
[Musique]
pourquoi est ce qu'ils tombent tous
amoureux
regardez quand même toutes ces heures
donc pardon saison qu'a donc à uap lisez
grégoire lyonnet toujours ensemble
reinvented denitsa ikonomova toujours
ensemble camille lacourt et sa danseuse
habile jaf anime toujours ensemble
paraître non non sur des amis notez donc
c'est vrai qu'il est libre la frite
daniel calmez-vous daniel elles sont
plus ensemble mais ils se sont séparés
il ya deux mois il ya deux mois je dois
alors je note de plus ensemble
il va pas rester sur le marché longtemps
donc ouais ouais mais je vous écoute et
vous nous direz il y avait aussi des
rumeurs mais ça on ne dit pas parce que
c'est des rumeurs on n'est pas un moment
donné aussi de matt pokora et 2 et 2 et
de alexandre car une receveur pardon je
trouve tout ça était faux mais il ya
beaucoup de rumeurs en tous cas il ya
vraiment des couples qui se sont formés
et avant qu'on en parle demain vous
montrer la version anglaise de danse
avec les stars c'est hallucinant il ya
eu 14 couples qui se sont formés et puis
ensuite je n'ai d'autre que je veux
raconter parce qu'il ya un mec qui s'est
fait choper mais non pas avec sa femme
regardable en angleterre on parle même
de malédiction il faut dire que nos
voisins britanniques détiennent la palme
ce ne sont ni un deux ou même trois
couples qui se sont trouvés grâce à
l'émission mais bien 14
ce qui fait donc autant de ruptures
alors l'émission est elle le nouveau
site de rencontre des stars
[Musique]
voilà et pour la petite info un candidat
donc 200 danse avec les stars étaient
photographiés en train
bravo tu êtes vous en train de tromper
sa petite amie avec sa danseuse c'est ce
nouveau rôle chez été photographié en
train de tromper son amie rebecca avec
sa danseuse
évidemment cette danseuse et de ce côté
marié aussi donc ils sont fait choper
tous tous les deux pourquoi est-ce que
danse avec les stars est devenue une
énorme
j'ai alors attention je vais citer sacha
guitry le tango je me demande pourquoi
ça se danse debout et on dit aussi le
tango c'est l'expression verticale d'un
désir horizontale la danse pourquoi vous
allez danser tout chamboulive ou parce
que moi j'ai jamais été en vacances
c'est évidemment pour draguer c'est du
parti ce matin on met on chauffer mais
aaron tu le fais péter sur 12 ans
[Applaudissements]
jeter un seau d'eau et excusez moi vous
mettez une belle fille avec un beau
garçon il se frotte il frotte à toute la
semaine pour répéter c'est normal alors
qu'elle se conclure j'aimerais qu'en une
info c'est parce que tu sois delphine
vous êtes très ami avec iris oui enfin
bon dans la musique
non je veux juste rebondir sur ce que tu
as dit daniel la danse et de l'art avant
tout donc effectivement les corses ont
collé mais il n'y a pas forcément de
traduction sexuelle en revanche là où
les couples peuvent se passe fréquemment
avec les stars c'est k danse avec les
stars y sont h 24 ensemble c'est à dire
du matin au soir dorment dans la
téléralité sacré dd ça crée des liens
c'est juste et vrai pourrait rien
non mais ça je ne peux pas dire que
c'est le vrai c'est notre rêve pas du
tout si c'est la jeune norma oui je dis
pas non je bats alors à un départ oui
dis pas non caprice mais c'est comme da
les tournages de cinéma deux films les
images qui par trois quatre mois tourné
ensemble il ya une histoire d'amour qui
serait soulagé ça veut pareil même à
ceux ci seraient c'est qu'ils restent
ensemble après alors qu'en règle
générale les histoires qui sont un petit
peu fortes comme ça en télé réalité
parce qu'on est ya yen très forte
émotion sur un sur un temps assez court
souvent derrière ça perry qui n'ont
alors nous c'est simple quand il ya un
dalle ce qui va sortir
on commence à avoir la liste des noms on
regarde ceux qui sont célibataires et
sexuellement compatibles et on se met
dessus et on est quasiment sûr on est
quasiment sûr d'avoir un couple à la fin
pourquoi avez vous justement la phrase
romantique glamour conneries et c'était
exactement la même chose c'est vrai il
ya quelques années on faisait ça sur les
tournages de films reprenez le film
français et vont regarder qui tournaient
ensemble on connaissait ce qui était
chaud bon voilà et on savait que quand
un couple de cinéma se faisait souvent
c'est un couple dans la vie mais hey
salut qu on sait que ça marche on sait
que ça marche en une danse avec les
stars c'est le carton jaune ils sont
beaux l'émission marche aussi en
vacances un peu moins la semaine
dernière mais bon et du coup quand même
ça oui ça va forcément aller avant de se
quitter à faire avant de se quitter
avant de passer à un autre sujet on a on
a un petit scoop sur un couple intrus
quelque chose n'en laisseras non la
rapprochement là pour l'instant tout va
bien la bastille mais rien ne dit c'est
que vraiment il en parle quand c'est pas
sûr
quelque chose